[Music]
in good advice news submitted by flamin
hot cereal Justin Bieber shared tips for
dealing with an anxiety attack on
Instagram I like Justin Bieber yeah you
can tell he's really live in his life
now yeah he's in my godson yeah he's
always writing about what's-her-name his
wife
hailey yeah hailey beer yeah hailey oh
he's married yeah he married married
when did he married her sis years Daniel
it looks like he lives in a trailer park
now yep
he probably owns multiple translated any
joy he likes by life yeah yeah yeah it's
like that kind of guy duh and he's in
white tank tops and it has a brother
named Skeeter yep are you sure to
Instagram this post that says tips to
help with an anxiety attack down first
look around you feel like that would
give me more anxiety then as you're
looking around you have to find five
things that you can see four things that
you can touch gonna count while you're
doing three things you can hear and two
things you can smell and one thing you
can taste that helps cuz it forces you
to focus on something else yeah present
I love how Justin Bieber is like a
BuzzFeed article right now well done he
ended up captioning it with my grandma
just shared this with me share if this
helps you but then the rest of the post
says this is called grounding it can
help when you are when you feel like you
have lots lost all control of your
surroundings please repost it could
really help someone in need so you see
my hip grandma shared this with him tip
the help with an anxiety attack yeah
look going
so the like therapists like experts
weighed in on this and said that this is
exactly like what you should be good dog
they like what's wrong oh yeah so oh
that's really cool well I just had one
last night but it seems like the world
gets completely blurry like so maybe
that's why I can see why you would try
to look right your surroundings I just
never try to eat
feel I go like this oh just make it stop
so you go far deep into your it feels
like I can't breathe so I hyperventilate
I mean everyone's different some people
have panic attacks without
hyperventilating I tend to
hyperventilate because I feel like I
have no control and like everything is
suffocating and I feel like everything's
like the weight of the world is on me
and then I'm like crying because but not
because I'm like thinking of anything
it's just because I'm scared because I
can't no control over anything and then
the world just feels like it's like
spinning too fast and so I'm just trying
to like I'm like hyperventilating and
the world spinning and I just like I'm
just like trying to like make it all
disappear but yeah so well if someone's
there like Steve knows now like for me
and this is different for everybody
because I know people that hate this but
for me if he squeezes me tight my
heartbeat and breath starts to matches
and then it really like brings me back
yeah and your straitjacket yeah like
yeah it really it completely covers me
but yeah I notice at home when you feel
his balls from the back yes it's it's
one thing I could touch the back and he
gets a boner while you're having an
anxiety attack when I cry so but no I
know some people that hate to be touched
when they're having an exact person but
I wish I would have known that yesterday
I would have tried it and then I would
have told you some results okay yeah the
five things you could see four things
you can touch three things you can hear
to ease you can smell and one thing you
can taste 5 yeah you just have to
remember the order of the senses yeah so
see touch hear smell taste oh there are
no order ok well they're trying to
remember I'm like here here here here
but it's like boom boom boom I don't
order of how personal things are because
then the last one is it's being ingested
all right Dylan smells it's in
the order of how personal because you
don't like taste the inside of your
mouth really huh you can't taste two
things at once oh I thought you said
something else you can only taste the
inside of your mouth no I heard you say
you can only taste one no I um I've
never had an anxiety attacks but I was
diagnosed with anxiety when I was
younger so I always felt that like
panicky like I'm in trouble yeah yeah
like oh and then I would always shake
fidget and shake my legs even my feet
inside my my actual shoes I had to like
do this to my toes like I was just like
insanely like I couldn't stop moving and
it always felt like that like looming
feeling that like I'm about to get my
ass what do you know I didn't get beat
as a kid but like it just felt that
feeling yeah um but I can't even imagine
what it would feel like to have like a
full-on it
panic attack yeah that sounds intense I
recently had one really yeah because um
well like I know I was trying too fast
right so for four out of five days every
2 to 3 a.m. I would wake up out of
nowhere and then my heart would be
beating and my chest will be tight right
and I was explaining this to my trainer
and he's like I think you need to eat
like that's just high stress and I'm
like oh I thought I was just you know
having sleep problems and he goes yeah
that's high stress and because your
body's in shock you need to come eat
with us and then I was like well I just
I don't know I mean like I just kind of
like brush it under the rug like it's
whatever's right and then we were all
we're about to eat
I started feeling this like same feeling
I'm like oh [ __ ] this is how I feel when
I wake up in the middle of the night and
then they're like oh you don't look so
good and Gilbert was there he's like man
looks like a bus just hit you you're
like you're losing color and all that
and I'm all like really well I just feel
like a tightness in my chest and my
heart's beating fast like I feel like
I'm running like but I'm not and then I
finally eat and after the food I start
to feel a little bit better and I go
home and Jess was like yeah I think you
just went through hypoglycemia which is
when your body
burns all the carbohydrates and it
starts eating its own muscle and all
that and that put and it goes into shock
right well that's an anxiety attack
right like the the in that the tightness
in the chest you feel scared when
there's nothing to be scared of because
I'm just sitting there like why does it
feel like I'm running from a tiger or
you know like something is chasing me
but I'm also not reacting in the way
where I'm registering it and it's making
me psychologically go oh my god this is
[ __ ] scary right it's more like I
feel these feelings and I'm like oh it's
probably something but my body's
reacting that way I mean very much fed
well so I I guess I had I was going
through that probably yeah and that's
probably why they're like you had
anxiety or whatever yeah tight chest all
that stuff yeah pounding sometimes like
the rooms a little bit yeah you get
dizzy and you're just kind of like you
feel like you're on a boat kind of like
that mm-hmm
yeah it's crazy but I'm also used to
that feeling if I if I'm doing something
high adrenaline well that makes sense
high adrenaline cause it's very good
yeah it's really triggering that but if
you're just sitting at your computer
desk and then all of sudden you just
like you have this panic attack that's
why they say high adrenaline sports help
with you dealing with anxiety mm-hmm so
like I have this video I call like deep
water sports and I'm sure there's it's
not limited to the ones that I do but
like stuff like BJJ or kickboxing or oh
my god like CrossFit or like or like
scuba diving or like anything where if
if you decide to fail you have extreme
dire consequences so for example at
basketball it's not to me it's not a
deep water sport is it means if you
don't want to play you just walk off the
court right but if you're if you're a
kickboxing you stop you put your hands
down getting knocked out and BJJ you're
getting choked out or if you're swimming
you know I don't want to swim anymore
you drown so there's like extreme dire
consequences for you quitting but being
able to control your breathing in those
sports in those high adrenaline sports
when you come back to a normal situation
and you feel the same way
you're able to kind of like breathe
yourself and talk yourself through it so
I actually like training in those sports
because it's like getting a little bit
of those doses every single day I think
it all tastes of death your micro dosing
on adrenaline basically interested your
micro dosing on a drum yeah I think it
helps you it really helps you put things
into perspective I actually had like a
attack on Monday remember I woke up at
4:00 a.m. so like when you wake up and I
was like oh [ __ ] oh man what the [ __ ]
going on and I had like a lot I liked a
lot of like work stress kind of built up
in my mind but the one I told you doc
and then I went to the gym and then I
was kind of like driving with my heart
rate heart rate went to two to teach
like this and then but when when you
train our ass off and then you're like
all you're worried about is oxygen
nothing really matters anymore
he's got a morning anxiety tech on
Monday morning I did - yeah anxiety I
don't know - just know I was like
Barbara okay
but it was like yeah I just thought all
kinds it's like but afterwards when I'm
like training or gasping for air then
whatever was this looming theme doesn't
really matter it has like a lot of
anxiety is triggered just by first of
all problems yeah I just jackoff
maybe not all right I like extreme
sports stuff does it make it but people
like it because it puts you in a Zen
mindset all the first won't problems
gets pushed aside if you're like life or
death right now
deep I like deep water sports - yeah
it's calling deep boy my whole theory
behind it is the fight-or-flight
response are more flight then anxiety
and adrenaline actually causes them a
more negative experience than maybe
people who likes fight so then if you if
you're attracted toward that at
adrenaline and you like a little bit of
anxiety and you thrive in that
environment I think you're more of the
fight response when something stressful
happens
things I'm you know or like thank you
stress yes
anxious definitely feeling but never to
the point of like anxiety or panic
attacks but just makes me happy to say
other people talking about that stuff
because it makes you feel better because
I don't get these no no because I can
imagine like a people at home who goes
through that stuff and when it comes
like health issues like people always
think like this is something that I have
to deal with on my own when you see
other people like talk about it you're
like oh [ __ ] like maybe I'm not that
messed up other people are going through
this yeah I I have like if I stress a
lot I get stress issues differently than
like most people but if I saw a lot of
people talking about it I probably
wouldn't feel as bad about it you know
what I mean so I can imagine from that
perspective that it's good that we're
all more open about this but I want to
ask you guys I don't know if I'm going
to deep sigh I'm sure I'll tell you even
more than you don't know you don't want
to know do you guys feel like we're
almost you know in a generation where
there's like an epidemic by this like
hustle girl Yeah right like you see
first world problems and it's like to
some extent yeah because like you know
we're lucky to have jobs to be worried
about but also I feel like if we're so
lucky to have these jobs like we should
have a mentality of being more happy
about the stuff that we have to I
suppose like I have to be doing better
engineering that does I think that it's
an evolution kind of thing because I
passed what is it not generations but
like eras yeah like past eras they had
different problems to worry about like
even just past generations like there
were wars going on around the whole
world and then now this is just like our
eras were war that we're dealing with
when it around ourselves yeah and I
think because it's so open now - um I I
feel like there's a lot of
self-diagnosing happening and a lot of
that could be not to say that I'm in
validating a lot of people here but some
people will use it as a crutch and just
and they if they're going through some
sort of adversity or something like for
me at least I'm like I as a as a human
species I feel like I have to go through
these feelings and at the like feel
these emotions of negativity because
that's what's gonna help me understand
what the [ __ ] just happened grow from it
so that the next time when it
happen then I know how to react yeah
instead of going like oh [ __ ] like I'm
just gonna I'm gonna shut down out
I think what's cool about this
generation though is that we're not
about suppressing yeah so everything is
out in the open so then we can have
these conversations of how to deal with
it when it happens versus the previous
one is like you're you're crazy
you're something if you have it
something's wrong with you you know you
got to work through that [ __ ] keep your
head down yeah yeah
[Music]